already one move on the board and I
think that gives us a clue Magnus has
gone back to his childhood favorite one
E4 he's played this throughout his
career and in situations where he wants
to draw I'm recalling the final game of
the 2016 world championship against
karyakin he forced to draw very quickly
in the Berlin
um he always seems to go back to this
opening 1e4 because there are forcing
variations there are forcing ways that
you can kind of guarantee you get a
stable position and also flashback to
one of his world championship matches
against Anand where it was the Sicilian
and he found a way to shut down anan's
activity
um so I think that's the name of the
game for the experienced Magnus Carlton
to shut down managera's fun and it is
the Sicilian good choice in a must-win
situation for black
and possibly if Magnus pushes his
Central Pawn forward the open Sicilian
will see what we call taimanov or the
Khan different variations with a lot of
tension so Magnus pausing now he doesn't
necessarily want to imbalance things by
pushing forward in the center yet yeah
I have to say though I've noticed Magnus
is the expert at managing to get very
simple very comfortable positions with
white uh I mean I remember many times
where his opponents have been in must
win situations and he just plays like
this he plays the open Sicilian he gets
a comfortable position and everyone is
just struggling against him and he
decides to pick his pick up his C pawn
move it two squares forward look at him
he's getting ready to close the position
down uh Magnus is just a genius what can
I say this is this is why he's the world
champion and wow I was about to praise
Magnus for being Universal but Mama
jarov pushing Gary the G4 two squares
you'll never see this in a serious game
from top players he's just forgetting
peace development he's throwing his
pawns forward he's trying to kick away
White's night with this Pawn it's
obviously not a good move because you
have to develop your pieces but he's
already trying to shock Magnus playing
on that psychological Factor
um this game is not going to be calm no
matter what a Magnus tries to do even if
Magnus tries to shut it down okay
stopping the advance of Black's porn now
Mama Joe he's just determined he's shown
us with that move he just wants to go
down in style and uh okay now we will
see an open Sicilian but what is Black's
Pawn doing on G5 it's so weak you can
even take it now do your van codes
it's just desperation from Shaq you know
he knows he's in a must-win situation
let's just play the kind of craziest
moves ever and I agree with David I mean
it's it's not good yeah
do not do this at home I mean as David's
mentioned you know the G5 Pawn is weak
and uh Magnus is just say hey I'm gonna
play it like a normal game and I'm
constantly gonna ask you why did you put
your Pawn on that square yeah and let's
just say my major office never prepared
this before because if you study this
this position with a computer you see
it's pretty much lost already for black
as we see on the evaluation bar that's
six moves six moves so he's freestyling
as you mentioned that word desperation
Ivanka maybe it's not showing enough
self-belief from Shaq that he has to
Freestyle like this but we also have to
commend him because he's entertaining us
showing us something we've never seen
before and it does remind me of a
position of a variation that I've seen
many times from someone who passed away
recently Mike Bassman a very influential
International master from the UK and he
used to like to start games with the
creepy crawly opening as we call it one
A6 on H6 just slowly edging forward on
the sides of the board creating
weaknesses and it just looks so ugly
it's so bad but there are reasons sir
you play it and that's mostly
psychological the opponent wants to
punish you and therefore they get too
carried away and they lose their
objectivity but Magnus it's gonna be
hard to unsettle him and this is the
downside of pushing your Jeep one too
far forward white is going to push and
undermine your Pawn structure whites
Rook on the edge file about to get open
and this is a direct consequence of
Shaq's last move which was probably
another in an inaccuracy because it
allows white just to blast open the
right side of the board I mean how is
black going to maintain his pawns on
there he can't he either has to trade or
or he he has to trade yeah there's
nothing for it or he can move his Knight
but that's not great either
uh he does take this Pawn but even if
Magnus doesn't go and capture this Pawn
with his Rook right now which okay he
has just done but even if he hadn't
Black's Pawn structure is ruined it's
wrecked can you imagine anywhere for the
black king to be safe
I think you have to stay in the center
because the black king is definitely not
going to the right anymore it's too open
over there White's Rook is ready uh for
an attack it definitely can't go to the
left side of the board you've got too
many pieces in the way you can't Castle
on that side either
um so Black's King is an eternal
I mean it's it's an eternal Target for
white this reminded me of us that song
Back In The Middle With You I said
Jokers to the right of me
yeah no the one that goes take us to the
right of me something clowns to the left
while I'm stuck in the middle with you
and it kind of that King is just there
you know what what are Black's pieces
doing yeah yeah and meanwhile I'm pretty
sure Magnus is going to be happy to
Castle the queen side to the left Castle
long as we say the White Queen at some
point will step into the battle and uh
yeah I mean she's gonna go all the way
to H5 yeah and oh actually she doesn't
doesn't even bother just uh keep it
simple and then White's King is getting
ready to Castle the pawn is under Fire
think think mama jaraf will will last
longer than 20 moves I think it's a
miracle if Mother of lasts to move 20 in
this game I've got to say let's just
show why Black's position is so hopeless
right now it's just riddled with
weaknesses and uh firstly this queen
Advance has lined up a direct threat
against this H6 Pawn it's now attacked
three times and it's just gonna fall uh
sooner rather than later and uh the
other reason as you say Ivanka I mean
for example if you develop a piece I
don't think White's going to get greedy
anytime soon white can just castle and
all of White's pieces are participating
these nights this bishop all
fantastically placed whites King is
going to be super safe in the corner and
uh yeah clear targets especially with
this bishop the white Rook can even
slide across and undermine this guy
black can't even develop his queenside
Knight if black ever moves this piece
out then white can just take white can
just capture and this Pawn would drop
maybe White Once More but at the very
minimum you're going to go up a pawn
yeah this position is so ugly and uh
poor managerov impressing us so much
with that g-pawn push but this is the
reason we don't freestyle in the opening
the consequence is you might get a
position full of holes and okay the
Knight moves to attack this Rook but the
Rook is just gonna shift you can step up
one square it can just step back the
whole way if you want to play it super
safe
any Rook move to safety and Magnus has a
decisive advantage too many sleep pieces
too many dormant uh black pieces over
here and no defense definitely Magnus
needs to be kind here and actually give
Mama jar of about five free moves and
then maybe and then maybe he's okay but
even that Anna is a maybe yeah exactly
big maybe
um I think I would just play it safe
here it's slightly tempting to go and
blockade this each Pawn but yeah if you
just play it safe Retreat The Rook okay
he does blockade in the end Magnus
Carson uh but yeah next move pretty much
automatically you Castle Queen side
okay he doesn't first he moves his
Bishop but he's getting ready to Castle
Queen side Magnus and when that does
happen that will signal the beginning of
the end potentially for managero for the
Knight firstly attacks the white Rook
okay he's found a good formation we've
got to give him credit
The Rook is going to be forced to
retreat
and uh okay there we go it Retreats a
bit of an odd Square in the eye line of
this bishop that's unexpected I mean of
course white is still massively better I
was gonna say go all the way to the
starting Square yeah I mean this Square
just looks vulnerable it's as if you're
giving manager of Hope somehow but yeah
if you push this Pawn forward to attack
this rook and attack the knight at the
same time white can defend that those
two threats in a very simple way White's
Knight can jump to block and this would
be very strong a capture does not help
black at all because actually white
would have full control over the light
squares instead manager jumps out with
his Queen to one side of the board but
Magnus I mean he wants to Castle anyway
watch King is going to be super safe on
the B1 Square
is manager of do you think Ivanka really
gonna try and copycat and Castle well he
would dream of her I mean that's just
I just act like a pipe dream or just
some ambition because as Magnus has done
just Retreat the night and the pawn on
D6 is hanging yeah I think we might see
this game finish quite soon
unfortunately for mamajaro if the queen
is hanging you have to move her no
matter where you go if Magnus wants to
keep it super safe he takes this Pawn
gets the Queen's off the board clear
Pawn advantage or you can even take this
Pawn remember this one is still hanging
it's attacked three times okay manager
puts his Queen in the middle of the
board but is this queen just gonna get
trapped at some point uh I guess his
idea if the white porn steps forward to
attack the queen which it has just done
is to give up his Knight but you're
gonna be a whole piece down and we see
the black queen trapped it's captured
the White Queen is captured but at the
end Magnus just wins a night for free
and Shaq has decided he's had enough of
that and Magnus takes the point wow that
was a quick game a quick day three games
Magnus wins them all